hello everyone thanks i'm al swigert and
this is my presentation recursion for
beginners a beginner's guide to
recursion
actually this is my presentation
recursion for beginners a beginner's
guide to recursion
i'm mostly known for writing this book
automate the boring stuff with python
and i've spent several years now
teaching python uh particularly
to beginners and trying to break down
really complicated topics uh and put
them simply and i've been thinking about
recursion because people think of
recursion uh as this advanced
intimidating topic
and really you know people think of
recursion is hard or recursion is
confusing
or they don't really understand
recursion so recursion seems like magic
at least that's what the google search
results say i really like
i like number five recursion is bad
um so i've spent a lot of time trying to
figure out how can we explain recursion
in a way that's very approachable so
i've put together this talk which
requires no background in computer
science you only have to understand the
basics of python programming to
understand this but before i get into
this talk
there is something i have to do
it's just something we have to get
through um so i'm just i'm just going to
go into it and that is go through all
the recursion jokes just get it out of
our system
to understand recursion you must first
understand recursion hahaha gets funnier
every time i hear it
there's the dictionary definition of
recursion which ends with c also
recursion
uh if you google the word recursion the
google search results will say did you
mean recursion with a link to the google
search results for recursion
i like my coffee like i like my coffee
recursive
i'm so meta even this acronym
is meta
and finally there's the mythical
creature the recursive centaur which is
half horse and half recursive centaur
so from these jokes we kind of get an
idea of what recursion is it's this sort
of
meta self-referencing
dreams within dreams kind of a thing but
here's a better definition for it a
recursive thing is something whose
definition includes itself for example
this is sierpinski's triangle it's a
recursive shape it's a fractal
and the way that you draw sierpinski's
triangle is by drawing an equilateral
triangle and then you put an upside down
triangle in the middle of it which forms
three other triangles and then you just
draw sierpinski's triangles inside of
those triangles so the definition of how
to draw sierpinski's triangle
includes drawing sierpinski's triangle
it's recursive
you can actually create this yourself i
have the code up on github it uses
python's turtle module which comes with
python you don't have to install
anything extra to draw these shapes
but a better definition for programming
is a lot simpler
in programming recursion is when a
function calls itself so here's the
shortest possible example of a recursive
function it's a function called shortest
and it only has one line a call to
shortest
and this seems really weird like does
this even work and it turns out no it
doesn't work it will show you it'll show
you this error recursion error maximum
recursion depth exceeded this is also
known as a stack overflow era
hey that's the name of that website
isn't it
now before we really dive into recursion
i really want to talk about stacks
that's the the stack in stack overflow i
feel like recursion is really difficult
to understand if you don't first explain
stacks and the call stack and this is
where a lot of recursion tutorials go
wrong they don't explain this one
concept
so really if we go back to this joke
this is completely wrong really if you
want to understand recursion you must
first understand stacks
so what is a stack a stack is one of the
simplest data structures in computer
science um
it's a data structure that holds a
sequence of data and only lets you
interact with the topmost item you can
think of like a stack of playing cards
where you can only see the topmost card
and you can only add or remove cards
from the very top we call stacks a filo
data structure because the first card
you put in will be the last card that
you take out
you can also think of it as like a
meandering conversation like i'm telling
you this story about my friend alice and
that reminds me of a story about my
friend bob and that reminds me of a
story about my friend carol and then i
finish that story and i start talking
about bob again and then i finish that
story and i get back to my story about
alice and finish that that's also a
stack
now there's two main operations that we
do with stacks that's adding something
to the top of the stack and that's
called pushing and removing something
from the top of the stack which is
called popping
now python already has
a built-in stack data structure it's the
list if you just restrict yourself to
using the append and pop methods of of
lists then you have a stack right there
we have some python code right here i
have a blank list in the spam variable
and i'm pushing some data onto it with
the append method and then i pop it off
and you can see that instead of the top
of the stack it's really the rightmost
side of the list but this works exactly
as a stack
so let's take a look at some code this
is just
really standard normal python code we
have functions calling functions we have
this a function that's calling a b
function which is calling a c function
and at the start and end of each
function we just have some print calls
to show you when it starts and ends so
when we call a this is what the output
looks like start of a start of b start
of c and then it goes in the opposite
order end of c end of b end of a
because when we do a function call and
we all kind of know this already but it
helps make it explicit when we do a
function call we're not sending the
program execution on a one-way trip to
some other part of our program python
will remember the line that made that
function call so it can return back
there afterwards if you've ever heard
the phrase go to considered harmful this
comes from about 50 years ago before we
really had functions and programmers
would just have go-to instructions to
send the the program execution to
another line of code and this made
debugging really hard to do because you
couldn't really tell the path that the
execution took to get where it was
so
how does python keep track of
where all these function calls should
return from and it keeps track with a
stack specifically one called the call
stack
uh you can think of back to that story
with alice bob and carol whenever we
make a function call we're going to push
what's called a frame object onto the
call stack and over whenever we return
from a function call we pop it off of
the call stack so the frame object
contains local variables and
where to return to and a few other
details i'm oversimplifying a lot of
stuff in this talk
but you can think of a frame object as
representing a function call
and recursion is a lot easier to
understand if you understand stacks and
the call stack i think the really hard
thing about wrapping your head around
recursion is that when you look at code
like this
you ask yourself like well where's the
call stack you can't really point to a
line of code and say here's the call
stack or this variable contains the call
stack
it's handled by python automatically
behind the scenes
so if you want to learn more about frame
objects in the call stack you can look
at the inspect and traceback modules
doug hellman has a great python module
of the week blog article on both of
these things
so the first thing that you need to
learn about recursion is that recursion
is overrated
um
no no so recursion is still an important
topic you should learn about recursion
it's very useful and very necessary but
i see a lot of people using recursion
when they don't really have to use
recursion and this this is especially
true for a few examples when we
introduce recursion to students and
beginners
there's a
few examples that are always used i'm
going to cover two of them right now the
first is factorial and i'm going to
cover why this is recursive and why it's
also a terrible thing to use with
recursion so factorial is a really
simple math concept uh 5 factorial is 5
times 4 times 3 times 2 times 1 2
factorial is 2 times 1. you can kind of
get the idea of how this works so if you
think about it factorial has a recursive
nature because 5 factorial is the same
thing as 5 times 4 factorial i mean if
you do the math it checks out
so for positive integers you can have
any number
factorial equals number times the
factorial of number minus 1. uh you can
see that the definition of factorial
includes factorial it has a recursive
nature there's a exclamation mark on
either side of that equal sign
so that means we should be able to write
some code that does this right we can
have a factorial function it has a
number parameter and it returns number
times the factorial of number minus one
and this seems pretty simple it'll work
right no it actually doesn't work at all
we see that recursion error again uh
that stack overflow and the reason that
happens is because five factorial is
five times four times three times two
times one but what our code is doing is
it continues to go to zero at negative
one and negative two and remember every
time we make a function call we're
pushing a frame object onto the call
stack and that's gonna use up a little
bit of memory so we can't do this
forever because eventually we'll just
use up all of the computer's memory
um and so what a stack overflow is is
when your recursive function doesn't
stop recursing and it keeps recursing
forever and then eventually it'll eat up
your memory um python actually has a
built-in limit of 1000 function calls
that you can make without
returning
this this limit is kind of arbitrary but
it's big enough for most purposes you
can change it although i really wouldn't
uh it's it's best to just think of it as
yeah just it's best if you just accept
that 1000 is the limit
okay so we need to change this function
um here's a hint 1 factorial is 1. so if
we just check if our number parameter is
one we can just return one
this is called the base case so it's the
set of circumstances where your
recursive function will stop recursing
and the other half of that is the
recursive case which is the code that
does the recursion
now
in every single function that you write
that's recursive you have to have at
least one base case otherwise it'll keep
recursing forever and cause a stack
overflow and you need to have at least
one recursive case because otherwise
it's not a recursive function if it
doesn't call itself so whenever you're
writing code
for recursion it's a great starting
point to just think what's my base case
and what's my recursive case and make
sure that your recursive case eventually
hits one of the base cases
um this is you know so like i've
explained that and usually that's where
a lot of people leave off but some
people are still confused because they
look at this code and say like well
where's where's the 5 times 4 times 3
times 2 times 1. you can see that one
multiplication operator at the end there
but like where does the series
of multiplications happen
so remember we're dealing with a call
stack here every time we call a function
we're putting another frame object on
the call stack so
our factorial function is exactly like
our abc function except it's factorial
calling factorial over and over and over
again just think about the the call
stack like that deck of cards you can
only see the top most card so this is
what the call stack looks like when we
do our recursive factorial function so
it starts in the upper left we're
setting number to five and in that
function call it has to return five
times factorial four which means we have
to call the factorial function again so
we're putting a new frame object on top
of the call stack and in this frame
object number is set to four notice that
there are multiple local variables named
number the the number that equals five
is still there it's just underneath the
topmost uh frame object
so that's another thing to that people
get confused on there's gonna be
multiple number variables
and so in that function call we call
factorial of three which calls factorial
two which calls factorial of one and
that's our base case it just returns one
it doesn't have to do any more recursing
so now we're returning which means we
pop the frame object off of the c
of the call stack
and that reveals that number the frame
object where number equals two and that
one can return now it just returns two
times one and that pops off and then we
return 3 times 2 then we return 4 times
6 and then we return 5 times 24 which
returns you know 120 5 factorial
so i hope that diagram helps but you
know it's still kind of confusing
factorial is actually a pretty bad
example to introduce someone to
recursion because you have this line of
code and half of this line executes
before all the recursive calls
the the number minus one part and then
the other half executes after all of the
recursive calls have returned the return
number times part it's sort of like i'm
telling you a story about number minus
one and then i get distracted with
multiple levels of other stories and
then i finally come back and i finish
telling the story of how return number
times that return value
um
so factorial really isn't the best
educational example for recursion
if you still find this a bit more
difficult to comprehend here i've sort
of hard-coded
several functions uh so there's
factorial five which calls factorial
four which calls factorial three and so
on and so on and you can see here like
oh here's where the 5 times 4 times 3
times 2 times 1 happens our recursive
factorial function is doing the same
thing except with just one function
instead of separate functions
and if that's still confusing to you
you can just use the iterative version
of this algorithm just a simple loop
it's fine
um
there's there's
no reason like recursion isn't
automatically more elegant than an
iterative solution
this code works it's pretty readable
it's great um
there's there's actually i mean
recursion is not more powerful than
iteration there is nothing that
recursion can do that you can't do with
just a loop and a stack
and i'll prove it okay so i've shown you
the recursive factorial algorithm and
i've shown you the iterative
recursive recursion recursive algorithm
i have also created a monster which is
the iterative
the iterative factorial algorithm that
emulates the recursive factorial
algorithm
behold
look upon my work see mighty and despair
this does calculate five factorial i
don't really have time to to explain all
the code but suffice it to say i've
created my own call stack with a python
list
i i have quote unquote frame objects
that are just python dictionaries that
hold the quote unquote local variables
even though there are no local variables
in here it's all global variables
because i have no functions it's just a
while loop
uh the body of the while loop has all
the same code as as the body of the
recursive factorial algorithm i split it
up into two parts there's the part
that's the start up to the recursive
call and then the second part is after
the recursive call to the end of the
function and whenever i quote unquote
call the recursive function i'm just
pushing these quote-unquote frame
objects onto the quote-unquote stack and
then whenever i quote unquote return
i am popping them off the quote unquote
am i doing that right yeah quote unquote
call stack
so this shows you can do this with any
recursive algorithm by the way
everything you can do with recursion you
can do with a loop and a stack there is
nothing magical about recursion at all
but please don't do this ever
okay so
you know if if recursion isn't more
powerful than iteration and recursion is
often uh harder to understand than recur
than iteration
why should we ever use recursion so i
thought about this a lot and i came up
with an answer and then i thought about
some more and i came up with a better
answer
recursion maps very neatly to problems
that have a tree-like structure and also
require backtracking you really need to
have both of these features for a
recursive algorithm to be very very
useful and and elegant
um fortunately there's a lot of stuff in
computer science that involve trees and
require backtracking a tree is really
just a node that branches off to two
other nodes and then these nodes branch
off to other nodes so it's naturally
recursive and if you think about it a
list is really just a tree that has one
branch on each node so list can also use
recursion as well
a maze has recursive solutions because
really a maze is just a giant tree that
you can from each node take one of
several paths from which take you to
another node and then you can choose one
of several paths from that every once in
a while you'll reach a dead end so
you'll have to backtrack
to an earlier node this is using a lot
of path finding and ai algorithms as
well
your file system on your hard drive is a
tree you have folders that contain other
folders that's that's recursion
so um if you don't have a
a need for backtracking in a tree-like
structure you really don't have to use
recursion when i showed you that uh that
example where you can turn any recursive
algorithm into a loop and a stack
technically you can do the opposite as
well you can turn all loops into a
recursive function
which i think is kind of madness but
recursion is is not magical it is simply
another tool that you can use
and sometimes it's a tool that you
shouldn't use like what if we try to
calculate the factorial of 1001 remember
python has a limit of 1000 function
calls so if you try this
the recursive factorial function doesn't
even work it just causes a stack
overflow there is a way around this
though and it's something called tail
call optimization or tail call
elimination so this is used when you
just have large problems that require a
lot of function calls if you redesign
your code so that the last thing what
the the tail of your recursive function
does is make the recursive call
then uh
technically
you don't need to hold on to the local
variables because there's no code to run
after that recursive call returns so
that means you can get rid of
the frame object for the current
function call off of the call stack
which means that the call stack never
grows inside i know i'm in size i know
i'm kind of rushing through this
but basically what this means is that
tail call optimization allows you to
prevent stack overflows that would
otherwise happen
but uh the thing about tail call
optimization is that it's really
overrated
so
look at our recursive function we can't
use tail call optimization here because
we have that number times part that
happens after the recursive function
call returns so we'd have to rewrite
this code so that we have that return
the return value of the of the recursive
call but that also means we need to add
this new parameter called the
accumulator and
that's really acting as a sort of global
variable almost and our base case starts
looking really strange also
and all of this is just to solve a
problem that iteration doesn't even have
in the first place
now the way tail call optimization works
is it's a compiler trick your compiler
or your interpreter will parse your
source code realize that you're making a
tail call and then it does all the magic
with the call stack behind the scenes
but the thing is the c python
interpreter does not implement
tail call optimization
and the other thing is it never will
so
the reason
other than that you have to it
encourages you to bangle your code but
uh there's another reason for it well
the short answer is it's simply
unpythonic
the longer answer uh is explained in a
few blog posts by guido van rossum so
you can't even use tail call
optimization in python it's totally
irrelevant and there's a there's a
second problem that we always use when
we're explaining recursion to beginners
and it's also a terrible candidate for
recursion and that is the fibonacci
sequence
oh yes it's great so if you don't know
about this it's a sequence of numbers
the first two digits are one and one and
the next digit is just the sum of the
two previous digits so one plus one is
two one plus two is three two plus three
is five and so on and so on forever um
you can write a function that says okay
find the nth fibonacci number and this
is going to be a recursive function or
it can be a recursive function because
fibonacci has a recursive nature
the nth fibonacci number is just the sum
of the nth minus 1 and nth minus 2
fibonacci numbers and the base case is
that the first and second fibonacci
numbers are both one so we can write a
function
like this
and it works for really small numbers
if you try to
calculate the 35th fibonacci number
that'll surprisingly take several
seconds and if you try to calculate the
100th fibonacci numbers that will take
several centuries and the reason is
because each call to fibonacci
generates two more calls to fibonacci so
it's like a hydra every head you cut off
two more grow in its place and this
means we're doing a lot of work an
exponentially growing amount of work and
worse yet
a lot of that work is redundant like
we're making multiple calls to fibonacci
4 or fibonacci 3 right here
so the trick around this
is to cache all the return values so
that you know the first time you
calculate fibonacci of 4 you remember
that so in future calls with fibonacci
of iv you can just return that cached
value instead and that prunes away this
tree and and removes all the redundant
work but again that's sort of a trick
you have to do
just so you can solve a problem that
iteration doesn't have to begin with
now this technique is called memoization
which your phone will always want to
auto correct to memorization but it's
memoization
um we can just you know create a cache
and then at the start of the function
check the argument return the cache
value if it's in there otherwise we'll
just later update the cache but python
is the battery's included language so
you can just
use the funk tools.lru cache decorator
and it does the exact same thing you can
do this with any function it's also good
outside of recursion but it's especially
useful with recursion
lru stands for least recently used it's
a very common caching algorithm
but again that's just to fix something
that iteration doesn't have a problem
with anyway
uh so i hope i've gone and explained how
recursion is is not this magical you
code sorcery thing that only the
mightiest of programmers can wield
in fact sometimes it's a completely
inappropriate way to solve your
programming problems
yeah so let's recap there's so much more
to recursion but i hope i've just
started you off with a lot of really
nice basics
the more you practice coming up with
recursive solutions the better you get
at sort of identifying the the general
gist of how recursion works but to recap
to understand recursion you must first
understand stacks and the call stack
this is the main reason why recursion is
so confusing to beginners is because the
call stack doesn't appear in your source
in your source code so it's easy to
forget about it and easy to forget that
it's there
you'll always need one base case and one
recursive case in your recursive
function and function calls push a frame
object onto the call stack and returning
from a function pops them off of the
call stack
and a stack overflow happens when you
never reach your base case and you just
keep making recursive function calls
over and over and over again without
returning
anything you can do with recursion you
can do with a loop and a stack there's
nothing magical about recursion
and using recursion only uh when you
have a problem that has a tree-like
structure and requires backtracking i
think backtracking is the main key there
otherwise it's not completely necessary
uh tail call elimination and memoization
are two tricks that help make recursion
practical to run on real world computers
uh tail call elimination is com or yeah
tail call optimization is completely
irrelevant to python because it doesn't
implement it in the interpreter
and that's it that is everything i've
covered i'm really glad that i was able
to get through all of this in 30 minutes
here's where you can download the slides
and you can reach me on twitter and at
email thank you so much and enjoy the
rest of the conference